ADAM POWELL: Hello,
everyone, and welcome to What
the Fragment.
So I'm Adam Powell.
I'm a member of the
Android Framework Team,
specifically on the UI Toolkit.
But I've spent a fair amount
of time with fragments
over the years here.
And hopefully we can go over
some interesting information
here.
So the first thing that people
tend to ask is why Fragments?
There's a lot of
information out on the web
as people have used the
API, gotten kind of familiar
with it, and, in some ways,
kind of gotten bitten by it.
There's a lot of
complexity there.
And in fact, some
members of the community
have put together a few
diagrams of just how complex
the Fragment lifecycle
can be if you combine it
with the full Activity
lifecycle as well.
So you can start up at the
top here, and we keep going,
and there's some more.
Whew.
OK.
Well, we got to the end.
So the blurriness that
you're seeing here
isn't just because it's a
low-res version of the image,
it's just your eyes glazing over
as you try and take all of this
in.
And this is kind of your
reaction after reading over it.
So why Fragments?
If this is kind of the
reaction that everybody
has had over the last few years
out in the developer community,
why is it still something that
we're pushing or promoting
as a way to build
your applications?
Well, to start
with that, we'll go
over just kind of a
little bit of history
about where Fragments came from.
So some of you might have seen a
Google+ post by Dianne Hackborn
this past weekend where she
went into some detail about
the Android component model,
and how it's really not intended
to impose a lot of
higher level architecture
on your applications.
Instead, it's really just meant
to be a series of smarter entry
points.
So in a traditional
program that you
might have seen in classes
or so on and so forth,
you start from a main function,
and you run to the end.
And you might start a message
loop in the middle there.
And what Activities really
give you to start with
is just kind of a smarter
entry point, a place where
the system can send you
other messages about what's
going on to your application.
And these are just turned into
callbacks on an object instead.
So there were some other goals
in the design of Activities
as well, which one of
those is that apps always
stay in the state
where you left them.
So in order to do that, you
have this well-defined Activity
lifecycle and a compact
state representation
that you can use so that
the process can die,
come back later,
restore from that state.
All of this is stuff that
you're probably familiar with.
Also, apps can call
other apps to complete
a task in the form of Activity
is called with intent.
And each one of those
flows is represented
as one of these encapsulated
units in the form
of these Activities.
So over time,
Activities just started
getting big and complex.
And basically, the way that
you deal with complexity
is that you factor
out smaller pieces
so that you can compose them.
Back in the
pre-Android 3.0 days,
we had this thing called
LocalActivityManager
that could work in concert
with a TabHost widget
that you can see here in the
old Gingerbread dialer app.
So each one of these pieces
in each one of these tabs
actually contained
a full activity.
So that kind of gave some
weird pieces of the code
there, in terms of how
the code would interact.
There are ideas in
the Activity lifecycle
that just really
don't make sense
in this kind of composed model.
And then this happened.
And we're not going
to talk about that.
So larger screens happened,
and larger screens
mean larger problems.
So we have this
idea of, how do you
want to present these multiple
small screens worth of UI
that you may have already built
in an existing application,
and then sort of scale that
out across other screens?
Is there a smaller
unit of composition
that you could use for that?
And so that other unit
of composition, spoilers,
is Fragments.
So this was introduced
around Honeycomb
to try to solve some
of these problems.
The first one of
these goals though
was really just to break up
these giant Activity classes.
And this is a
problem that happens
whether you're dealing just
with small phone screens
or if you're trying to scale
across many different screen
sizes.
And it's just kind of natural
that as app complexity grows,
so does the complexity
of these big entry
points that can grow to be
these god objects if you're not
careful.
We also kind of wanted to
fix some of these problems
with LocalActivityManager
for when you do compose them
in these smaller constructs.
So you have lots of
these abstractions
at the Activity level that
just don't work well when you
start composing it this way.
These are usually things
that aren't quite as well
covered as, like, the Core
Activity State diagram.
But they're all
cases that still need
to be handled in a
general purpose solution.
One of the other things that
we wanted to do with Fragments
was to encapsulate
navigation state.
So the state of your Fragments
can represent the full state
of your Activity
in a way that can
be preserved through state save
and restore through a process
def.
So we have things like an
Activity-local back stock,
which some people find
useful and some people don't.
But managed dialogs was
one of the other things
that this really
tried to address.
Dialog Fragment is something
that a lot of people
do use at this point.
And it's because you basically
get the state restoration
for free if you
rotate the screen
or go through any other
sorts of config changes.
Back before Fragments,
this was handled
by just kind of this
first-class facility that
was provided by Activities
where you refer to a dialog
by its ID.
There's this whole other
creation process involved
in terms of, like, yes, I
want to create the dialog
with this ID.
We would persist that ID
and try to build everything
back up from scratch.
And that ended up just being
very one-off and kind of
awkward to work with.
And the final goal
of that was probably
the most obvious in terms of how
we pitched the API when it was
first released is this
idea of decomposing
these master/detail UIs.
So if you have two
screens, that on a phone
might look something
like this, where
you've got a list
of conversations,
as well as the actual
conversation itself.
As you drill down
by tapping into it,
use the Back button to get
back to where you were before.
In another
configuration, you can
take what's essentially
the same code
and have it look like this.
So this is something
that you might
be familiar with from a lot
of UIs that you've seen here.
And since then, we
kept building on it.
So we had ViewPager and
the FragmentPagerAdapter,
which a lot of people
still kind of think
is the way to use
a ViewPager, just
because we don't have a
stock adapter for dealing
with just bare Views.
So we've got
Loaders, which allow
you to do similar
things of persisting
some sort of a request
across configuration changes,
keep it going, whether or not
the lifecycle might otherwise
interrupt.
Ian Lake has a
great post on Medium
about this that
all of you should
go read if you haven't as well.
And then we also had this
idea of child fragments.
So I mean, if you can nest
one level deep in terms
of putting Fragments
inside an Activity, well,
why can't you put Fragments
inside a Fragment?
So that was an idea that
had a lot of support
in terms of a lot of
developers were requesting
this, both within Google and
external developers as well.
And it got added I think
sometime around the Jellybean
time frame.
So how did it work out?
I mean, some of
you kind of already
know the answer
to this question.
But these are sort of what we
took as stewards of the API,
as some of the lessons
from Fragments.
So the first problem
is that Fragments
are so general that
they become really
difficult to explain to people.
So is it just a pain of a UI,
like in the Gmail example?
Is it something like dialog
Fragments and something meant
to deal with manage dialogs?
Or is it something different
altogether, like you can still
have headless Fragments that
can act completely independently
of anything else?
And we didn't give a
whole lot of guidance
in terms of how to use these
things because we kind of felt
like we didn't want to be
too prescriptive about it.
And that ended up
really hurting us.
So of course, the idea of
even more life cycle to manage
was really kind
of a killer here.
And the bugs really didn't help.
This is really what
killed a lot of people.
Whenever I've
talked to developers
about what they would change
about the Fragment API
or what problems they have
in using the Fragment API,
a lot of times what happens is
that you build up a Fragment
transaction, you commit
it, and then something
works completely differently
from how you expect.
It's not particularly
intuitive, some of these things.
And it might kind of remove the
entire point of a bunch of code
that you just spent a
lot of time writing.
So this was another thing that
caused a lot of misconceptions.
I mean, Fragments, they're
just kind of like Views, right?
I mean, you can stick
this Fragment tag
in one of your layout
files, inflate it,
and you get a Fragment for free.
In hindsight, the Fragment
tag was this great piece
of syntactic sugar that
really confused people
a lot more than
it helped in terms
of just general education.
So this immediately made people
think that Fragment equals View
and that this is on the
same level of abstraction.
So if we kind of know where
things went off the rails,
then how might we start
trying to use Fragments
a little bit more effectively?
Well, the first
thing to keep in mind
here is that
Fragments are roughly
equivalent to an
Activity in terms
of the level of abstraction
that they act on.
They're composable entry points.
And their lifecycle
and inputs are really
controlled by
their surroundings.
They optionally manage
a UI presentation.
And they're really part of the
whatever in Model View whatever
in terms of the
architectural patterns
that you may be using
within your application.
They're not Views themselves.
And they're really
not meant to be.
Seriously, they're not
just fancy View groups.
Fragments implement UIs
just by using Views.
They compose Views.
They wire things up
to Views in order
to do something
more interesting.
And this really comes
down to a core idea
that isn't communicated
all that widely
that we kind of keep this idea
of an abstraction hierarchy
across the different
packages in the framework.
And the higher level packages
are things like android.app,
whereas the Views and widgets
are further down the stack.
And what this means
in practice in terms
of the organization of code
within the Android framework,
is that anything
at a higher level
can import anything from a lower
level, but not the other way
around.
And if you go
looking through AOSP,
you'll probably find a couple
of places where we mess this up.
And yes, we know it.
We're sorry.
But overall, it's managed to be
a pretty good way of organizing
some of this stuff
and making sure
that things keep a level
of responsibility that's
kind of appropriate for
that type of component.
So an example of
this is that you
might have a
Fragment that depends
on a View
OnClickListener in order
to implement that interface.
This is an example of
a Fragment just kind
of applying policy to a series
of Views that it's using.
Come on.
So while Fragments
can depend on Views,
and implement the interface
as exposed by those of Views,
it's important to remember
that the Views have
no knowledge of Fragments, that
fragments really kind of sit
as the policy layer
above whatever
UI that you've built visually
and out of the structure that
is used to generate input
events, so on and so forth.
So really, they're kind of a
glue component in this case.
They provide coordination
of these different View
components, or even of other
components within your app.
They allow you to wire
up the View events,
the Input events that you may
be generating from those Views,
and tell them something
interesting to do.
And all of that ends up
being driven by a knowledge
of the external lifecycle.
What's going on outside the app?
What's going on
outside the context
of that particular
Fragment or Activity?
So this is something that
others have definitely said,
and I will totally echo here.
Don't use a Fragment when just
a composite custom ViewGroup,
or even just a layout
resource that you can use an
include tag, will
do the job better.
A lot of times people
use this as a point
where they can pivot, where
they can decide what type of UI
to show based on
other conditions.
And between the resource
system and custom ViewGroups,
you can solve that
problem without getting
into lifecycle constructs.
The real question
to ask when you're
talking about using a custom
ViewGroup or a Fragment
in these cases, is does
it implement mechanism
or does it implement policy?
Is it an isolated widget that
generates its own input events?
And these might be
really complex as well.
I mean, we've got some things
in more recent versions
of the Support Library
like CoordinatorLayout
that are able to impose
very complex behaviors
on their child views,
things that you
can push and pull and move
around, swipe to dismiss,
so on and so forth.
But all of those essentially
are still just the user
acting on the UI.
You might be able to
swipe a snackbar away.
You might be able
to click a Apply
button on a snackbar in a
CoordinatorLayout or something.
But what that actually
means to the application
is policy that's imposed
by some other component.
And that's more where
Fragments sit in the layering.
So we also can't
talk about Fragments
and dealing with some of
the associated complexity
without talking
about saved state.
So the navigational
state of your application
is partially composed by the
Fragments that are currently
attached to it.
These may have
changed over time.
Contents may have shifted during
flight, so on and so forth,
where, if you have something
like master/detail UIs, then
you might have a very
different Fragment that you're
showing if you were drilled
into item A versus drilled
into item B in that list.
And that's something
that, ideally, you
don't want to have
to track yourself
in terms of other state.
As it gets restored,
as your process dies,
you come back into it,
so on and so forth.
So that means that setup of
Fragments is conditional.
And this is another one of
those kind of weird things
that everybody sees
when they first
start working with Fragments.
Well, why am I doing
this extra check
here when I'm setting
up this initial state?
And that's partially
because the Fragments
are going to be restored as
part of that onCreate call.
Now, this has historically
gotten a little bit
weird in that, if you were
dealing with child fragments,
when that reinflation
happens, really
wasn't consistent
with the way that it
happens with Fragments that
are attached to Activities.
Now, over the last
several months
we've really kind of dived
into the Fragment APIs
and tried to clean up
a lot of these cases
where the behavior was just
unexpected or inconsistent.
Because these are the things
that really made everybody
hate the API to start with.
So as of Android N and Support
Library version 24, which
is available as part of
the preview SDK right now,
child fragments are, just
as with Activity-attached
Fragments, they're
consistently re-inflated
during the super.onCreate
call that you
make within your own code.
So that way, after
you make that call,
you know that those
fragments that
were stored from instance state
are attached to your Activity.
You can do find Fragment
by tag and actually expect
to find it there.
You won't end up
with duplicates--
[APPLAUSE]
--when you try to
deal with that case.
Thank you.
So that alone makes things a
whole lot easier to deal with.
AUDIENCE: With all the
legal state exception.
ADAM POWELL: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: With all the
legal state exception.
ADAM POWELL: The
illegal state exception?
Which one?
We'll get to it in a minute.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So again, we keep coming back
to this idea of Fragment states
and that giant diagram.
So how do we just stop worrying
and love the lifecycle here
because every one of
these stages of lifecycle
really does represent a
significant event that
can happen to your application.
And just because we
have a lot of them
there doesn't necessarily mean
that you have to care about all
of them all the time.
A lot of Fragments
that you'll write
will only implement a
couple of these methods.
But just having all
the options there
can be really overwhelming
when you're just
looking at documentation.
So that big flowch--
I couldn't tell
you everything on
that big flowchart
at once off the top
of my head either.
But the nice part about
this is that you really
don't have to hold all of
that in your head at once
because even though those
interactions look very complex,
really, the Fragment lifecycle
is driven by what's essentially
a single integer value.
So this is straight out of
the Fragment source code
where we have these six states
that Fragments move between.
And the nice thing
about these states
is that this isn't like a
completely connected graph
of states, this is linear.
So when Fragments move
from one state to another,
they move through all of
the other states in turn,
dispatching the appropriate
methods to the Fragment
to deal with those
lifecycle events.
So this leads to something
really kind of convenient,
which is that all you
need to think about
is what invariants do I need
to enforce for my new state?
You can keep your thinking
very much constrained
to each one of these
individual lifecycle methods
so that you don't have
to worry about the state
of the entire
application in aggregate
when you're dealing with this.
More importantly, you can
say, what minimum state
will this component be in?
Or what can I count on?
Since again, the fragment
states are linear.
So if you know
that you're up all
the way at the
resumed state, you
know that you've been through
all of the other methods.
And this is one of those
things that kind of
seems obvious in hindsight.
But again, as you're looking
through the smorgasbord
of methods that you can
override on Fragment itself,
sometimes this kind of
gets lost in the noise.
So let's go ahead and talk
about a few other things.
We talked about one bug fix
that was pretty significant,
which is that the
child FragmentManager
state is guaranteed after
the super.onCreate call.
Now, this is subtly
different from what
I said earlier about restoring
Fragments from instant state
because there was this really
kind of a fun bug that happens.
So how many of you use
executePendingTransactions
for some part of your
work with Fragments
or have tried in the past?
OK.
Keep your hand up
if you ended up
regretting doing that during
a debugging session later.
OK.
Yeah.
That's a pretty close
match for some of that.
So executePendingTransactions
is this really handy method
on the FragmentManager
that tells it, OK,
all of those things
that you've queued up
with FragmentTransaction.commit,
do all of them
right now, all of them
that you've got pending.
And that's got a couple
of interesting issues
with it that we'll
get into in a minute.
But one of the interesting
things about that
is that you have
expectations after that call.
Specifically, if you've
committed one or more Fragment
transactions before
that, then you
expect those
Fragments that you've
committed in that
transaction to be brought up
to a particular state
in the lifecycle,
usually matching the container.
Well, it turns out
that that wasn't
actually how things worked.
Some of you probably
found this out.
And this, again, came
down to this idea of what
happens with child fragments.
And you're probably noticing
a bit of a theme here.
So what would happen instead is
that the child fragment manager
itself wouldn't be brought
up to the new state
until long after the
parents onCreate returned.
So all of these invariants
that should make it a lot more
easy to reason
about your program,
especially when you're saying
that, hey, resolve everything
right now,
executePendingTransactions,
well, all that just kind
of went out the window.
So that made things a lot more
difficult. That's now fixed.
So again, you know
that you don't
have to worry about that after
the call the super.onCreate.
So executePendingTransactions
had another kind of problem
as well, which was that it makes
everything happen right now.
And the issue with that is that
different parts of your program
might be committing
Fragment transactions
at different times.
So as soon as you say
executePendingTransaction
in one piece, you may have
just caused a side effect
to that effects
some other library
that you imported
that uses Fragments,
and you didn't
even know about it.
So we went ahead and we
added a commitNow method
to FragmentTransaction,
which basically
does the same thing,
but really kind
of what you wanted
instead, which is, no,
just this transaction.
Commit this one right now.
This does have one
particular limitation, which
is that you can't deal with
Fragments on the back stack
if you use commitNow,
just because if you have
other Fragment
transactions pending,
you don't want to create
inversions in your back stack
in terms of when
those really apply.
We also added a Fragment
onAttachFragment method
to match the Fragment Activity
and Activity onAttachFragment
method.
This is kind of
useful when you want
to go ahead and configure
a Fragment as it's
being attached to its parent.
If you want to do any sort
of injection of dependencies,
if you want to do any sort
of wiring up of listeners
within that local
Activity for other events
that it might publish, this is
a pretty good time to do it,
except there really
wasn't a good place
to do this with child
fragments before.
This was something that
was entirely skipped.
You couldn't even do it
in the parent Activity
if you wanted to because it was
only ever called on the parent
Activity if and only if the
Fragment was attached directly
to the Activity, not
any of the children.
So a few other notes that
are kind of useful here.
This is one that some developers
ran into fairly recently
as we fixed some other bugs
around Fragment transitions,
which is that to obtain the
state of a Fragment transition,
we have to interrogate
the Fragment.
We have to call a
method on the Fragment
to get the transition values
and what it should do.
But in order to make that
make sense to that Fragment,
we have to bring the Fragment
up to the created state
before we ask it
about the transition.
So what that means,
in effect, is
that we have to bring some
Fragments up to the created
state before they
become fully attached,
or before they replace
whatever Fragment that they
were replacing before.
So this is one of those things
that's good to be aware of.
Don't assume that just
because your Fragment goes
through the attach
and create steps
that all of the
other surrounding
state about a
FragmentTransaction
has necessarily happened yet.
Again, this is
something that you
want to make sure that you keep
your thinking within a Fragment
implementation scoped
just to that Fragment.
Make sure that it's not trying
to take on responsibilities
outside of itself.
And again, they
really work best when
they can behave as isolated
from their surroundings.
One of the things
that I see people
do a lot is that when a
Fragment becomes attached,
and again, just because
you have problems
with state restoration
of more complex objects,
it's pretty common for
people to say, OK, well, when
I get attached to
my Activity, I'm
going to go ahead, grab the
Activity, and go fishing.
I'll go ahead and
check out if I can
find other Fragments, other
sibling Fragments by tag,
grab any other sort of
associated information
from that Activity, down
cast it to a specific type,
so on and so forth.
And while this ends up
being pretty convenient,
it also means that
those Fragments suddenly
become a whole lot less
reusable elsewhere.
And while you may not care about
that right from the outset,
it is one of those things that
tends to come back and bite
people later on.
And then they wonder, why didn't
we have some other facility
to do this, to do a cleaner
injection of the dependencies,
so on and so forth.
So that was a lot of
information really fast.
And some of it
probably didn't answer
a lot of the core
questions that you
may have had coming in here,
which is, I really don't
like this API that I've used.
Why should-- like,
change my mind.
Why should I go back and
give it another chance?
And really, the core
issue here is that apps
aren't getting any smaller.
So when you start working,
especially across a large teams
and across code bases that have
lasted for a very long time,
architectural patterns don't
end up being universal.
And this is part
of what Dianne was
trying to get to in her post
over this weekend as well.
If you have a very
long-lived code base,
then what was popular and
the obvious way that everyone
should build their apps back
when the code base was started,
isn't necessarily true when
you're maintaining it years
down the road.
So one solution to that
is to try to create
standard, smarter components.
So how many of you have
taken a look at integration
steps for some
library for Android,
and you see something that
looks kind of like what's
on the slide here?
OK go ahead and add this
snippet to your onCreate,
this other thing to your
OnStart, this one onStop.
I'm pretty sure that some of
our own libraries from Google
have these types of
instructions as well,
things where you need to
call some particular method
from some part of
your lifecycle.
And really, that just makes
these integrations really
kind of messy.
So instead of that,
well, we could just have,
well, add this Fragment instead.
And we'll go ahead and take care
of those extra lifecycle steps.
And that suddenly makes it a
lot more reusable and a lot less
error-prone.
And the nice thing
about this is really
that-- or even better, you can
just use one of these tags.
I mean, even though we had
issues around general education
around Fragments on
what they can do,
it's really powerful
to be able to say,
here's a piece of my UI.
I just want to drop this
completely self-contained
component here, and
then not think about it,
to be able to just configure
it, possibly from other XML
attributes as specified
there, and then just let
that component do its thing.
So the idea here is to
really try and provide
these single points of
high-level integration
that everyone can use.
And that last part
is really key.
Again, not everyone
is going to be
using the same architectural
patterns that your app does.
And your own app may
not use those patterns
the same way over time either.
But Fragments are kind of
uniquely positioned here.
And that's because Fragments
really closely mirror
that Activity lifecycle.
There are a few
differences here and there,
but by and large, as you're
thinking about invariance
to enforce within a
Fragment, they really
match what you do
with Activities
as part of that core entry point
idea for Android components.
So that means that
essentially they
can sit below that
level of abstraction
of your higher-level
architecture
that you impose upon
your application.
And that makes them reusable
as components in the same way
that Views are
reusable to Fragments.
So when Fragments
are communicating
with the rest of the
world, you really
need to be careful about
the types of configuration
dependencies that
you end up creating.
Again, this comes
down to that issue of,
are you going fishing
in your parent activity,
or in your parent
Fragment for that matter,
for other dependencies?
And is that Fragment
going to blow up
if those things aren't there?
Are those dependencies
documented?
How is someone who's using
that Fragment necessarily going
to know that that's
a requirement?
Now, in a code base
within a particular team,
again, this may
not be a problem.
But as things grow
over time, we tend
to see a lot of these
patterns show up.
And that means
that you really do
need to consider your
audience as you're
building these things.
If you're building
libraries, the answer to this
is going to be a
lot different from
if you're just
building another screen
within your own application.
In your own application, sure,
go ahead and take a dependency
on some internal component.
I mean, it might help.
It might hurt.
But at the very least,
you're not passing this out
to the rest of the wider world.
And also, if you are
offering the ability
to use Fragments that are these
standalone drop-in components,
the onInflate method is sorely
underused in some of these.
So this lets you do the same
thing that you do with Views,
specify some
configuration attributes.
It might be something
like an API key.
It might be something like
any other sort of information
that you need to pass to
that Fragment as arguments.
But you can do it without
having to muck around with it
and code necessarily
during that initial startup
phase of your application.
Because again, you want to
try to have one integration
point with these things.
Thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]